salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique en cette période de
pandémie
le laboratoire de virologie des 4 2 où
anne est source de beaucoup de fantasmes
et d'interrogations ce laboratoire
permettant théoriquement d'étudier en
toute sécurité les virus les plus
dangereux a été vendu par la france à la
chine en 2004 vendre un labo de ce
niveau à une dictature et est
franchement une bonne idée on peut en
douter
et pourtant ce n'est pas la première
fois que la france au nom de la
recherche et de la coopération
internationale fournit une technologie
dites duales c'est à dire la fois civile
et militaire
un régime dictatorial aujourd'hui je
vous propose de découvrir un précédent
qui s'appelle aux irak dans les années
70 les dirigeants français dans leur
immense sagesse ont eu la bonne idée de
vendre un réacteur nucléaire à l'irak à
l'époque le pays est dirigé par le parti
baas le parti nationaliste et socialiste
panarabe de saddam hussein et ce depuis
quelques années suite à un coup d'état
en 1975
saddam alors vice président se rend en
france où il rencontre le premier
ministre jacques chirac et le président
giscard et visitent le centre de
recherche nucléaire de cadarache
nos deux pays signent la même année un
accord de coopération nucléaire
les liens économiques entre la france et
l'irak étant alors très fort l'irak est
le premier client de la france au
moyen-orient
aussi bien pour du matériel civil que
militaire et est notre second
fournisseur de pétrole pour les
dirigeants français il semble donc
normal d'exporter notre savoir faire
dans le nucléaire auprès de ce pays avec
lequel on s'entend si bien bien l'accord
de coopération nucléaire est au point
nous l'avons même complètement arrêtées
combien de centrales gens
l'irak qui n'a alors que de petits
réacteurs de laboratoires de très faible
puissance envisage un réacteur de mille
700 mégawatts et sa dame ne cache pas
ses vues clairement militaire à terme ce
type de réacteur permettant de produire
du plutonium militaire
mais finalement à cause des traités de
non-prolifération
c'est un petit réacteur de 70 mégawatts
qui sera construit copie conforme du
réacteur de recherche français osiris
est dénommée osirak parce que les
français aiment les jeux de mots voire
même au chirac parce que certains sont
mauvaises langues et qui sera appelée
tamouz par les irakiens qui n'ont pas du
tout le même sens de l'humour ce
réacteur ou plutôt c'est réacteur osirak
et une version miniature appelé isis
seront construits sur le site irakien de
tout état qui accueille déjà les
réacteurs de faible puissance et seront
gérés jusqu'en 1989 par des équipes
françaises sous le contrôle de l'aiea
l'agencé internationale pour l'énergie
atomique
mais si le réacteur et le faible
puissance il utilise tout de même un
uranium 235 fortement enrichi à plus de
90% soit du combustible de qualité
militaire et ce partenariat ne laisse
pas indifférent au moyen-orient israël
en conflit avec les régimes arabes
baassiste et viscéralement méfiant on ne
sait pourquoi vis-à-vis des dictateurs
un moustachu antisémites va tout mettre
en oeuvre pour empêcher le régime
irakien d'accéder à la technologie
nucléaire début 1979 un groupe du mossad
les services secrets israéliens fait
exploser la cuve du réacteur alors en
construction en france puis élimine à
paris un ingénieur nucléaire égyptien
travaillant sur le projet la cuve sera
réparé et cela ne stoppera pas la
construction du réacteur osirak côté
irakien en juillet de la même année
saddam hussein fait un putsch et devient
le seul maître du pays
l'année suivante éclate la guerre irako
iranienne une tuerie qui fera la part
belle aux matériels français
de 1980 à 1988 la france vendra pour
près de 60 milliards de francs d'armes
irak des mirages f1 des chars des canons
on prête même des super étendard équipés
de missiles exocet le tout souvent à
crédit et sans aucune réserve
les iraniens bombarderons osirak sans
succès les israéliens eux toujours aussi
peu enthousiaste à l'idée de voir un
pays voulant les rayer de la carte
disposer d'équipements nucléaires
décidée en 1982 frapper fort
fini les commandos discrets les
opérations à la james bond
ils lancent l'opération opéra un raid
aérien au cours duquel un escadron de
chasseurs maquillé en appareils
jordaniens pour ne pas éveiller
l'attention larguera 6 tonnes de bombes
sur le site nucléaire le détruisant en
partie et tuant au passage un employé
français de la société air liquide
suite à ce raid condamné à
l'international le vice-président
irakien tarek aziz se rend chez ses amis
français pour leur demander gentiment de
reconstruire le réacteur pour son
premier contact officiel avec les
nouveaux dirigeants français le
vice-premier ministre irakien tarek aziz
est porteur d'un dossier de la clause
importance obtenir de la france qu'elle
reconstruisent le centre nucléaire de
tammouz détruit par l'aviation
israélienne le 7 juin dernier
il faut rappeler que l'irak est notre
plus importants clients au moyen-orient
ainsi que notre deuxième fournisseur de
pétrole
or tout cela va dépendre de la réponse
de la france
quant à la reconstruction de tammouz le
président irakien saddam hussein a
déclaré publiquement qu'en cas de refus
il s'adresserait à d'autres pays pour le
programme nucléaire ainsi que pour le
développement économique de l'irak après
des négociations impliquant donc un
petit chantage économique
c'est de bonne guerre la france accepte
de reconstruire le réacteur avant de se
rétracter en 1984 les irakiens ne
disposeront donc plus que des
générateurs de recherche de faible
puissance obtenue auprès des soviétiques
sans le bombardement israélien il est
probable qu après 1989 les irakiens qui
aurait pris en main la gestion d'osirak
aurait pu mener à bien leur projet de
bombe atomique
grâce au matériel français en le
détournant de son usage originel mais
l'opération opéra ne va pas pour autant
mettre un terme au programme nucléaire
irakien saddam hussein comprend après
cet épisode qu'il ne pourra rien faire
aux yeux de tous avec les agences
internationales dans les pattes et les
services secrets et demi sur le qui vive
aussi après 1981 l'irak va continuer sa
quête de l'armé nucléaire
mais dans le plus grand secret pendant
une décennie dix mille personnes vont
être employées sur une trentaine de
sites clandestins impliquant toutes les
étapes de l'industrie nucléaire de
l'enrichissement d'uranium à la mise au
point de giv ce programme ne sera
découvert et stopper qu'après la guerre
du golfe
voilà donc comment par avidité
commercial et bêtises les dirigeants
français ont failli permettre un
dictateur déposséder l'arme atomique
cette vidéo est maintenant terminée si
vous avez appris des choses n'hésitez
pas à la partager et à vous abonner à la
chaîne et sur ce il ne me reste plus
qu'à vous dire à la prochaine